[Music]
make America corrine again Wow oh my god
et spent a luxurious day with miss
luxury herself Corrine elympios luxury
yellow corn getting pedicures and
drinking Corinne's favorite champagne at
the Four Seasons in Los Angeles Corrine
Sundance pod as we look back at her big
bachelor moments where did make America
Corrine again come from was that a
phrase that you came up with I think so
yeah I was um I had a few glasses of
champagne was going on the show harder
than you thought it would be ultimately
it's emotional it's nonstop it's a lot
everything's heightened least favorite
moment on the show um when I had to
shovel poop let's be ah slow and
deliberate with her scooping discussin
why was that a date why was that a date
I'm still confused by that
I feel like deeply upsets me it like
disturbs my soul that they made me do
that there are some of the secrets that
you were maybe surprised to see in the
mansion there's laxatives in every
bathroom what if pooping is very hard
when you're doing all of that I'm sorry
but pooping it's a real thing everybody
does it and you know what it's hard when
you're there we're all bloated and we're
like oh tying my heart is gold but my
regime is platinum what exactly is a
platinum machine what I did it a really
good one it's very good-looking I mean
if you have a sterling silver vagine
that's the worst Oh
you